OVER FROM NEW YORK.
GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY ALL GOOD
NEWS.
IT’S NOT.
MY HEART IS TROUBLED.
WE’RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
FACTS, NEWS INFORMATION THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA DON’T
WANT TO GIVE YOU.
PROTESTS CONTINUING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
BRAND-NEW FOOTAGE FROM THE
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD.
IT SHOWS HOW A CROWD OF
ONLOOKERS, THIS IS VERY HARD
VIDEO TO LOOK AT, BEGGING,
BEGGING ONE OF THE OTHER
OFFICERS AT THE SCENE TO STEP IN
AND STOP WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
GEORGE FLOYD.
MINUTE AFTER MINUTE AFTER
MINUTE.
IT’S EXCRUCIATING.
WE WILL PLAYED WITH A WARNING.
MEANWHILE, ANARCHY AND
LAWLESSNESS REIGNS SUPREME IN
SEATTLE.
THE POLICE PRECINCT THERE HAS
BEEN ABANDONED BY CITY
OFFICIALS.
ANOTHER PRECINCT IN MINNEAPOLIS
WAS BURNED TO THE GROUND A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND RIOTS THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE HONOR OF
OR MEMORY OF GEORGE FLOYD.
800 COPS HURT, SOME DIED.
WE KNOW ONE IS PROBABLY ON LIFE
SUPPORT FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE.
NOW BY THE WAY WE GO TO THE CITY
OF ATLANTA OUT THERE LAST FRIDAY
NIGHT 27-YEAR-OLD MAN NAMED
RAYSHARD BROOKS WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY AN ATLANTA POLICE
OFFICER.
THE OFFICER INVOLVED IN THE
SHOOTING WAS FIRED IMMEDIATELY.
IT’S JUST BREAKING, SOME 19
ATLANTA OFFICERS HAVE NOW
RESIGNED AFTER WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN THIS CASE.
WE WILL HAVE DETAILS IN A
MINUTE.
THE OTHER OFFICER ON THE SCENE
WAS PLACED ON ADMINISTRATIVE
DUTY.
THERE ARE GROWING CALLS FOR
ROLFE TO BE CHARGED WITH MURDER,
VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
HAPPENED WITH GEORGE FLOYD.
WE’LL GO THROUGH IT IN GREAT
SPECIFICITY.
ALSO YEAH, TO BECOME A MORE
PERFECT UNION, REFORMS ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED, WAY OVERDUE.
MORE TRAINING, MANDATORY
CAMERAS, MORE NONLETHAL OPTIONS
FOR THE POLICE MUST BE MADE
AVAILABLE.
WE CAN DO IT WILL HAVE MORE ON
THAT AND ONCE AGAIN WE NEED TO
PUT ALL EMOTION ASIDE.
LET’S START BEGIN WITH FACTS.
AS I’VE BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS, I
LOVE BODY CAMS AND I LOVE
CAMERAS INSIDE PATROL CARS.
THEY ARE EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT REALLY
HAPPENS.
THAT’S WHY I DIDN’T WANT TO SEE
THE SHOW "COPS" CANCELED OR
"LIVE PD" CANDLE BECAUSE WE GET
TO SEE THE DIFFICULTY ME IN THAT
JOB AND IT KEEPS EVERYBODY
HONEST.
POLICE RESPONDED TO A CALL.
A MAN WAS PASSED OUT AT A
WENDY’S DRIVE-THRU LITERALLY
BLOCKING THE DRIVE THROUGH.
UPON HIS ARRIVAL THE OFFICERS
APPROACHED.
RAYSHARD BROOKS AND ATTEMPTED TO
WAKE HIM UP.
>> WHAT’S UP, MY MAN?
HEY.
HEY, MAN, YOU’RE PARKED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DRIVE-THRU LINE
LINE HERE.
YOU ARE GOOD?
>> POOL SOMEWHERE.
ARE YOU GOOD?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ARE YOU HERE FOR A VISIT?
>> I’M VISITING.
>> WHERE ARE YOU VISITING?
>> MY MOTHER’S GRAVE SITE.
>> I’M SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
HOW LONG HAS SHE PASSED?
>> PROBABLY ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF NOW.
>> Sean: LET ME CORRECT THE
RECORD.
NOT 19 GUYS IN ATLANTA.
I CAME ACROSS THE WIRE AND WE
BEEN ABLE TO CONFIRM IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON SOME POLICE
OFFICERS IN OTHER CITIES THAT
ARE LEAVING THE FOREST, LEAVING
THE JOB.
SOME RETIRING AND SOME OUTRIGHT
QUITTING.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE VIDEO
FROM BOTH RAYSHARD BROOKS AND
THE POLICE, COURTEOUS,
PROFESSIONAL.
MR. BROOKS OBVIOUSLY VERY TIRED
BUT HE WAS ALSO RESPECTFUL.
AS YOU SAW, THE POLICE OFFERED
CONDOLENCES FOR MR. BROOKS’
MOTHERHOOD RECENTLY PASSED AWAY.
COURTEOUS, CARING, PROFESSIONAL
ON EVERY LEVEL ACCORDING TO WHAT
I SEE.
A FEW MOMENTS LATER AFTER
SUSPECTING BROOKS WAS
INTOXICATED, THE POLICE
PERFORMED AN ALCOHOL SOBRIETY
TEST.
WE HAVE THAT VIDEO TOO.
>> MR. BROOKS.
WE TAKE A PRELIMINARY BREATH
TEST FOR ME?
YES OR NO?
>> I DON’T WANT TO REFUSE
ANYTHING.
>> YES OR NO.
COMPLETELY UP TO YOU.
>> YES, IT WILL.
>> WAIT HERE WHILE I GRAB IT.
>> TRIED TO MAKE SURE YOU STAY
HERE.
>> I KNOW.
>> YOU SCARED ME BECAUSE YOU
WERE SLEEPING.
WE ARE WANTING TO MAKE SURE
YOU’RE OKAY.
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW.
>> TAKE A DEEP BREATH IN, PUT
YOUR MOUTH OVER THE MOUTHPIECE,
LOW AS HARD AS YOU CAN.
BLOW, BLOW, BLOW.
STOP.
YOU HAD ABOUT ONE AND HAVE
DRINKS.
YOU DON’T REMEMBER WHAT KIND?
>> NO, SIR.
I REALLY DON’T.
>> I THINK YOU HAD TOO MUCH TO
DRINK TO BE DRIVING.
PUT YOUR HANDS BEHIND YOUR BACK.
>> Sean: AFTER THIS MOMENT
WHERE WE SEE THE HANDCUFFING,
BOTH SIDES ARE POLITE,
PROFESSIONAL, CORDIAL.
BROOKS FAILED THE SOBRIETY TEST.
NO OPTION FOR THE POLICE AT THAT
POINT.
HE WAS OVER THE LEGAL LIMIT.
POLICE ATTEMPTED TO VERY
CORDIALLY EVEN AS YOU CAN SAY,
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY.
UP UNTIL THIS MOMENT, WHEN WHAT
WE THANKFULLY SEE EVERYBODY FROM
WHAT I CAN SEE AT THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR.
COURTEOUS, POLITE, ET CETERA.
BY THE BOOK.
THAT’S WHEN AT THIS SECOND,
EVERYTHING GOES SOUTH.
NOW THIS IS A VIEWER WARNING.
WHAT YOU’RE ABOUT TO SEE FROM
THIS POINT FORWARD, IF YOU HAVE
KIDS IN THE ROOM, ITS EXTREMELY
GRAPHIC.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PUT YOUR HANDS BEHIND YOUR
BACK FOR ME.
PUT YOUR HANDS BEHIND YOUR BACK.
HEY, STOP FIGHTING!
STOP FIGHTING!
YOU’RE GOING TO GET TASED.
STOP.
[BLEEP]
THE TASER!
STOP FIGHTING!
[BLEEP]
HE’S GOT MY TASER.
>> Sean: SEEMINGLY AS YOU CAN
SEE IN TAPE COME OUT OF NOWHERE
THE MOMENT THE POLICE TRIED TO
COVER MR. BROOKS, THE VIDEO
SHOWS RAYSHARD BROOKS FIRST
RESISTING ARREST AND THEN
ATTACKING BOTH POLICE OFFICERS.
YOU SEE THE STRUGGLE.
BOTH OFFICERS, YOU CAN SEE HER
HIP.
YOU HEAR THE POLICE ON TAPE
CLEARLY SAYING OVER AND OVER,
STOP FIGHTING, STOP FIGHTING.
WE’LL HAVE TO TEASE YOU.
STOP FIGHTING.
STOP GRABBING THE TASER.
AND THEN ULTIMATELY MR. BROOKS
GRABS ONE OF THE TASER’S.
HE STOOD UP, THE COPS ARE STILL
ON THE GROUND.
THE VIDEO SEEMS CLEAR AS
MR. BROOKS IS RUNNING, HE TURNS
AROUND AND IN FACT, THIS IS WHAT
THE APD IS SAYING, SEEMS TO FIRE
THE TASER.
THE OFFICER AND FOOT PURSUIT,
OFFICER ROLFE.
HE RESPONDED BY SHOOTING
MR. BROOKS TWICE IN THE BACK
WITH A HANDGUN.
HORRIFIC SCENE.
AS YOU WATCH IT, WHAT IS SO, SO
SAD TO ME ABOUT THIS IS UP UNTIL
THAT VERY SECOND WHEN THEY
ATTEMPTED TO HANDCUFF HIM, THE
EXCHANGE WAS POLITE,
PROFESSIONAL, AND ALL COURTESIES
ON BOTH SIDES.
ALL OF THIS DID NOT HAVE TO
HAPPEN.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THIS.
THE BROOKS FAMILY, EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.
YOU HEARD WHAT SOUNDED LIKE
GENUINE NICENESS, RESPECT FOR
MR. BROOKS OF THE POLICE AND THE
POLICE TOWARDS HIM.
EVERYBODY HAS TO LOOK AT THIS
AND WISH THIS NEVER HAPPENED.
THIS IS NOT LIKE, NOT AT ALL
LIKE THE 8 MINUTES AND 46
SECONDS ON TAPE OF A COP WITH A
KNEE ON THE NECK OF GEORGE FLOYD
BY THE ACTIONS FROM THESE
OFFICERS ON THE SCENE WILL
RIGHTLY BE SCRUTINIZED.
MOST LIKELY I WOULD GUESS BY A
JURY.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE ACTUAL LAW,
WHEN I FIRST SAW THE GEORGE
FLOYD VIDEO, IT WAS UNIVERSAL IN
THIS COUNTRY.
MAYBE A FEW KEYBOARD WARRIORS
COME ANONYMOUSLY TWEETING OR
WRITING SOMETHING ONLINE IN
THEIR BASEMENT.
CONSERVATIVES, LIBERALS, NOBODY
DISAGREED.
THAT TAPE DID NOT LIE TO US AND
I’M GOING TO BE CONSISTENT AS
I’VE ALWAYS BEEN ON THIS PROGRAM
AND BY CONSISTENT I MEAN THIS.
WE DON’T RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
WE BELIEVE IN DUE PROCESS.
WE BELIEVE IN THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND FOR GOOD REASON.
WE CONTACT SOURCES.
WE TALK TO WITNESSES.
WE LOOK AT VIDEO.
WE GATHER EVIDENCE.
WE LOOK AT THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND.
THAT’S WHY WE WERE RIGHT FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE CASE OF MICHAEL
BROWN AND OFFICER DARREN WILSON.
SO MANY OTHERS WERE WRONG.
SO MANY OTHERS RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
THAT’S WHY WE PREDICTED IT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT TO CONVICT THE
OFFICERS SIMILARLY WITH THE
MURDER IN BALTIMORE OF FREDDIE
GRAY IN THE AFTERMATH OF THAT.
WE ARE ALSO RIGHT ABOUT DUKE
LACROSSE IN THAT CASE.
THE UVA CASE, THE KAVANAUGH
ACCUSATIONS.
I LEARNED MY BEST LESSON FROM
RICHARD JEWELL WHEN I WAS A
LOCAL HOST IN ATLANTA AND SO
MANY MORE.
ACCORDING TO GEORGIA STATE LAW,
THIS IS WHAT THE POLICY IS.
THIS WILL MATTER IN A COURT OF
LAW.
POLICE MAY USE DEADLY FORCE TO
APPREHEND A SUSPECTED FELON ONLY
WHEN THE OFFICER REASON HE
BELIEVES THAT THE SUSPECT
POSSESSES A DEADLY WEAPON OR AN
OBJECT, DEVICE OR INSTRUMENT
WHICH WHEN USED OFFENSIVELY
AGAINST ANY PERSON IS LIKELY TO
RESULT IN SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
YOU KNOW AFTER THE STEALING OF
THE TASER, MR. BROOKS
IMMEDIATELY BECAME A SUSPECTED
FELON.
THAT WOULD BE A FELONY.
BUT IT’S A POLICE TASER A DEADLY
WEAPON OR DEVICE?
COULD IT BE USED TO SERIOUSLY
INJURE SOMEONE IF THE TASER AND
THE ELECTRODE WIRES HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DISCHARGED?
BROOKS ALREADY SHOT THE TASER AS
HE RAN AWAY FROM THE OFFICERS.
GEORGIA LAW ALSO PERMITS DEADLY
FORCE FROM POLICE.
THIS IS THE LAW.
"WHEN THE OFFICER REASONABLY
BELIEVES THAT THE SUSPECT POSES
AN IMMEDIATE THREAT OF PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE TO THE OFFICERS OR
OTHERS OR WHEN THERE IS PROBABLE
CAUSE TO BELIEVE THAT THE
SUSPECT HAS COMMITTED A CRIME
INVOLVING THE INFLICTION OR
THREATENED INFLICTION OF SERIOUS
PHYSICAL HARM.
CLOSE BUT NOT ONLY DID
MR. BROOKS INITIATE THE
CONFLICT, HE ALSO STOLE THE
TASER, AIMED AT A POLICE
OFFICER, SHOT IT.
WE CAN SEE ON TAPE AND WE HAVE
THAT VIDEO EVIDENCE.
THAT’S WHY I LIKE VIDEO CAMS ON
COPS AND INSOLENT CARS.
THIS WOULD’VE BEEN AT THE END OF
THE DAY WHAT WE CALL A SIMPLE
DUI.
NOBODY WANTS IT, BUT IF YOU
DRINK, YOU ARE A RISK TO OTHERS.
PROBABLY IN THE FIRST OFFENSE,
IT WAS THE FIRST DEFENSE,
MISDEMEANOR CHARGE, YOU GET
BOOKED, SUMMONS, COURT DATE AND
YOU CALL SOMEBODY TO PICK YOU UP
NEW HOME ASSUMING A FIRST
OFFENSE, LIKELY ALCOHOL